learners permit premieres next week on
my youtube subscribe today
hey guys the night pants nation tour is
underway indianapolis you're up next
september 30th through october 2nd
baltimore one night only october 23rd
brea california october 28th all tickets
are available at
ryansickler.com go get yours today
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler thank you for
your support i can't tell you how much
it means to me but i'm going to it means
the [ __ ] world to me thank you
uh for really leaning in man i i'm so
stoked i love seeing this community grow
um go to ryanstickler.com come see me
live all right we sat here for what the
better part of a year and a half in this
tiny ass room coming out to you and
now i'm coming to see you guys all right
so go to ryancichler.com check out the
dates there night pants nation tour is
going everywhere i will be doing some
dates with segora as well um go to ryan
sickler subscribe to the newsletter
you'll be the first to know about that
stuff and uh the patreon i just i'm
telling you man
if you're subscribed and you don't know
we just talked to a dude that that
solved an 18 year old cold case by
finding a [ __ ] human skull on his
work site okay there's not another
patreon out there like that for five
[ __ ] dollars all right you get the
honeydew a day early ad free at no
additional cost
and um
if you sign up for a year you get over a
month free all right so
uh merch is restocked the honeydew
podcast is the website the ringtones are
out there we're working on getting them
on the website now for your android
users and i do want to tell you the the
series i told you about it's taken me a
while to do it because i wanted to do it
well but it's called learner's permit
it's with my stepson
uh during quarantine
he needed driving hours and i was like
[ __ ] i need content so i got gopros
stuck them in the car
and uh we made a little 10 episode web
series together that i'll be releasing
here in a couple of weeks and be telling
you more about it so there's the thing
that's all the info uh you know we do
over here we highlight the low lights i
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers this storyteller is
coming back
for another episode very excited to have
this guy here this show was probably
probably made for him and nobody even
knew it ladies and gentlemen jason ellis
is back welcome back to the honey dude
it's great to be back it's an honor to
be back oh it's an honor to sit across
anybody with a gold tooth brother yeah i
don't know i like that you keep it i
don't i i feel like the older i get the
more it'll suit me
because i'm more i'm way past lit
so at this point
it's it's you i look like a tough [ __ ]
at this point because you're like
he got that [ __ ] in prison yeah i'm
gonna fight louis j gomez and he is the
greatest opponent of my life it's the
perfect fight for an old
pile of [ __ ] that like really likes
mixed martial arts
and he's not very good
and he's
not a real athlete and he's kind of he's
kind of old
as well like i think he's like 39 or
something so i'm 49 so i'll be 50 when i
fight him so we're both
mediocre but we're both pretty tough
and we both care a lot about
um
the sport like i think we both
want to be real fighters and we can't be
and this is re this is it's one of those
things where we're gonna really fight
and it's the same rules it's sanctioned
it's a pro mma fight
but to me i know that
we're not good enough to be in bellator
no one would ever sign us we suck
but it's a fair suck-off
you know
it could be tough to sell that
it's a fair sucker
and it's kind of like remember when
girls had boxing fights in the 80s they
didn't defend themselves as well it was
more of like a bond burner so that's
what i think this is more of a i think
this has the potential to be more of a
slugfest okay because there's not a hell
of a lot of precision do you see it
going rounds or [ __ ]
it's like one round of all health breaks
loose
i'm gonna my plan is knock this [ __ ]
out in 20 seconds
so i want to go get a cheeseburger and
[ __ ] you know i mean
hang out smoke a doobie i'm not built
for this anymore i what made you decide
you guys were actually going to do this
um he just
somebody said
you know ellis would clean the floor
with her and he was like [ __ ] and
then he like tagged me and i was like
come on man
don't start [ __ ] you can't finish and he
was like
i'm pretty sure i could [ __ ] beat you
and i was like
i know you can't and then he was like
all right i'll fire and then it just
accidentally got into i was an instagram
thing where i was like i would smash you
easily dude
and then
he said prove it
and i was like i didn't realize at the
time it was before i got job from sirius
it was before oh so this has been you
build up for a while then i blew my knee
out right after i said i'd fight him
so i went skateboarding on vacation and
blew my knee out and had to get a mcl
cadaver like a dead person's ligament
installed in there
after i'd agreed to fight him and he was
like oh you're getting a dead person's
ligament put in your leg another chance
it's easier for me to get better to beat
you
so we can like agree to fight way later
in later on down the road so i can
practice a lot while you are all old and
hurt and [ __ ] and i've seen them all
doing their videos they'll talk to each
other it's like he's uh he's old he's
like 50 he used to be good at
skateboarding like yeah he used to i'm
like [ __ ] you have no [ __ ] idea who
i am like none of you're all funny and i
respect you for being [ __ ] funny late
at night at a nightclub but i got up in
the [ __ ] morning and did sports dude
my whole life my body's built for
[ __ ] smashing you have no idea oh
pain i can't breathe or like my arm hurt
[ __ ] off i was at your place after you
jumped out of that [ __ ] car and i
thought you're gonna be crippled for the
rest of your life i can't believe you're
moving around and comfortable like you
are right now is there still some pain
lingering a little bit i see a
specialist yeah but what's a little bit
to you a full what's what would you say
on a daily basis uh one to ten your pain
is
oh four six seven nine three i'm
man okay when i got real hurt i mean
dude i jumped i feel like 40 feet to my
ass i saw i did 35 mile an hour and drop
to my ass still serving me chips over
there and everything i that that still
hobbling around serving the chips and
[ __ ] what are you gonna do
out there grilling he can't move as a
helmet
it only hurts to sit down yeah it's not
so bad i see i figured it out now it's
past that it's healed i got some lady
that does some crazy body work to
because i guess a bunch of stuff
switched off from the impact like uh
all the muscles went into shock in my
booty like a lot of my back legs and all
that stopped all the muscles stopped
firing off correctly so i had to go see
a specialist to like uh get everything
to fire off because you start to
compensate from your injuries and don't
use the muscles correctly and if i'm
trying to still skateboard starting
trying to get ready for a fight that i
really plan on winning so i've got to
have like whatever i've got left
to work with me so i got somebody that i
learned this from skateboarding like if
you're hurt and you think you can grind
it out you can grind it out but if you
go see people that adjust your [ __ ] and
get you to be better balanced and in
less pain and more flexible you have
more chances of winning the fight and
when you're 50 and you already didn't
want to [ __ ] do it in the first place
i'm done did i mean like this fight when
this is done i know it's like it's
insulting to hear a [ __ ] idiot that's
already been famous that something's
talk about being a comedian but
i wanna i wanna go do something else and
be super passionate about it and i
finally am okay with it not hurting
like you can offend me but i i don't
wanna be in another sport where you
somebody cracks me i get punched in the
[ __ ] head or somebody i don't i don't
i don't want to do it anymore i know
people are like oh you're gonna you're
gonna need to no no i don't i won't need
to be in pain
or in danger for the rest of my life
i i don't blame you i you got me
thinking about fights um in my life and
and i wanted to ask you about like
like the best girl fight you've ever
seen because i want to tell you this i
while you think about it i um
you know in high school most girls
grabbed hair yeah every now and then
you'd see one that you would grab and
she'd take the hand like this and
wouldn't necessarily punch like this but
give him that beating you know i'm like
oh okay you got brothers yeah and um
i'll never forget the girl that lived
next door to me i probably shouldn't say
her full name just in case her name was
shannon and she had older brothers that
were bikers and [ __ ] and she was a sweet
cute girl my age
um and there was a kid on the bus uh
that was 9th grade we all rode the high
school bus together she lived next to me
and it was another friend of ours in the
neighborhood over we all ride the bus
together so
um these younger kids would pick on them
because he was just a big soft kid you
know and gentle and
he was a pushover yeah and the younger
kids will pick on them and [ __ ] and one
day
um actually we're 10th grade a ninth
grader is picking on him on the bus and
he's finally he finally pushed enough
buttons
that our friend had had enough and we
got off the bus and where it dropped us
off uh was this church
um and as a it's a weird thing but if
you've ever seen the movie
uh that that uh johnny depp is in um the
oh my god i can't think of it now it's
gonna drive me nuts but he doesn't have
a painted face does he no it's a [ __ ]
um
it's a john waters film
um oh cecil b no not cecil beat them
it's gonna drive me now i can't even
believe right now i'm failing this i i
should fail at life i'm no help sorry
crybaby
okay goodbye baby tracy lourdes remember
tracy lord's a porn star she was in this
yeah yeah
so it's in maryland whatever the and
this this
church
is a just a wide shot of this thing
called the chatterbox orphanage in this
movie that's the church that our bus
driver uh that's our bus stop drops us
off and there's a cemetery in the back
of it and we get off the bus
and the kid's picking on my buddy and my
buddy just has had like i said had
enough and pick somebody he's big he
lost all that anger and he just boom
puts him on the ground he's just
giving it to him was he crying while he
was punching him no it wasn't like um
christmas story okay you know he's like
he's just had enough it's been years
yeah so he was not crying now he's like
i'm gonna you [ __ ] okay you're
gonna get all of it yeah you know
and he's got him and he's on all fours
and he's pinned him under and he's just
going
and this [ __ ] [ __ ] this girl that
none of us like that rode our bus runs
up behind my buddy and i mean
justin tucker punts
his [ __ ] balls from the back i mean
you could hear the thud
and my buddy just instantly grabs his
balls and rolls over i'll never forget
he's just gonna somebody get her that's
what he's crying
that's when he started crying
man hitting the balls and to
automatically cry oh cause remember
you've never seen a video
where somebody's beating up a guy and
then the guy grabs the other dude's
balls and then he like
begs him to let go of all at all costs
let go like i never had anybody grab my
balls where i do where i do that but it
seemed like a whole different kettle of
fish of a fight it sounded like she held
a football like because i'm punt like
perfectly
so
he rolls off the kid runs away
and this girl shannon my old next-door
neighbor
wasn't [ __ ] having that shannon i'm
telling you her brothers were bikers
older dudes she was denim on denim she
got a metallic or a t-shirt yeah does
she have skills or is it more of a
street brawl mentality she's got the
mentality we don't know here in the
uppercuts we don't know she's got the
skills yet
we're about to find out okay so shannon
walks up to her
the next day on the bus oh wow and walks
up to her on her own and goes those boys
have been picking on this kid and we
didn't even know she gave a [ __ ]
it's like those boys have been picking
on this kid for years and he finally
stands up for himself and puts your
[ __ ] friend in his place and you jump
in and hurt that boy like that guess
what [ __ ] today when we get off this
bus i'm [ __ ] you up and then goes
boom and sticks one in her face just to
let her know it's really and the girl
had glasses her grass is broken went all
up on her face and she was scared to
that's how the bus ride started yeah
but to promise another ass whooping
after the punch in the face is
you got to live with that that's
back then we don't have phones like oh
[ __ ] you know but we're doing that we're
like oh you're about to get your ass
kicked yeah everyone's cheering everyone
because we can't do it we can't hit that
girl no he wanted to [ __ ] do
something and we were like thank you so
shannon's got her and shannon makes sure
she gets off the bus first so the girl
can't beat her and run she goes and sits
up front and gets off and waits for him
we're like oh [ __ ] and this girl gets
off and the girl had big boobs i i
remember because we saw i don't feel
like that helps in fighting it didn't
and shannon just grabbed she's like look
i don't want to shannon grabbed her and
brought her in and i mean yeah she had
fighting skills she she [ __ ] punched
her right in the face again and put her
on the ground and just started going
and then my buddy takes the girl's
binder and just starts skipping through
the cemetery throwing all her paperwork
and books and ribbons oh man [ __ ] you
go [ __ ] get this you [ __ ]
that's what i'm doing and she is [ __ ]
her up and she rips her shirt off so all
the boys can see her titties coming out
yeah she did it like thank you shannon
thank you thank you everything oh dude
she did she really did wow
so to this day that girl's got this
she's about a good book man that girl
[ __ ] like i'm telling you it was
like it was real fighting out god damn
man god damn yeah there's like i feel
like there's because if you're a street
fighting girl and you've had a lot of
street fights against girls that don't
have street fights then there's a way to
win that fight that is not the same as a
mixed martial arts ability but if you
have a hold of a hair and you if you
you've got to go side to side so they
never get to stand balanced
and then you when you flick them to the
side when they go to get up it's an
uppercut uppercut and then you
make them go again so they keep going
often direction and fall into the ground
and it's just constant uppercuts to the
face and they never get to get on their
on their feet to throw a punch
those girls win every time
unless
it's a girl that goes to like my uh muay
thai gym
and then then then it's the because then
you've got a really tough girl who has
taken a lot of shots to give shots
and beating up a lot of women in a lot
of fights so she's not scared of getting
hit and then there's a girl that's a
trained
weapon that is going to land a lot of
shots before she realizes that she
should stop before she gets biscuited
because i've seen that before you have
you know you go to nightclubs with
fighters
and drunk people still
they don't they it's weird maybe more
now because i don't go out i'm older but
when i when mma was first
a bigger thing people didn't know and
would kind of push back on people that
had cauliflower ear and i go why would
you push that guy yeah is it not
apparent that he's gonna [ __ ] smash
you yeah no oh [ __ ] okay he's giving
up intentionally one of his five senses
it just seems
it just seems so apparent is it worth it
what's your background has it been like
the last 20 years of your life crushing
people because that dude looks like it's
been 20 years of crushing people and
when they're sort of like hey mate don't
don't do that you know the guy's
teaching he's telling him he's telling
you not to do it because it's gonna be
bad for you and you because you know
that guy's life looks like if if his ear
was a representation of his life that's
what that dude's lived you know what
i've seen people that are really good at
fighting and a fight has broke out near
me and i'm like oh [ __ ] and i look at
him and he's like
this is funny look at these guys and i'm
like oh [ __ ] they're coming close to us
and he's like
good like let him
come close to me and i'm like
wow you can kill anybody in the world
and now i see how apparent it is i am
like oh [ __ ] people like big dudes
coming over here and he's like
maybe they'll bump into me
and i know
somebody oh yeah cause that's not really
he's the one i wish somebody
you think girls don't do that like you
think girls that are good at mma and a
drunk girl is talking [ __ ] and they
don't go
i mean i like
are you sure and and it's just i feel
like it's the same drunk girl drunk guy
doesn't make a difference if you say i'm
sure to somebody and they're drunk and
they've already started talking [ __ ]
they're gonna back it up and then they
get beat up bad
but it's never bad i find real good
people just give you one or two
to stop you from like i've never seen a
really good person
knock you out and like hit you again
when you're knocked out or whatever you
ever see um you ever see the opposite
you ever see somebody get lucky and
catch somebody and like holy [ __ ] that
dude over there just
clipped him on the chin and got him wait
and drop somebody yeah just like a wild
shot might actually
you have yeah a lot of times
i don't know what that means
the person's a regular
what do you mean
like i'm saying it about my talking [ __ ]
and they actually
can [ __ ] fight yeah well i mean dude
it's not that
you
okay some people are probably naturally
better than others but it's also
i mean if you are drunk and you throw a
punch at someone's face it doesn't take
much to make someone go to sleep yeah it
doesn't like if i haven't been training
my whole life and i don't see you throw
it and it lands anywhere across here and
i don't see it this [ __ ] right here
tends to be everybody's like a light
switch yeah that right now some people
this is like next snap it's like bigger
skull people that get hit and they go
whoa what the [ __ ] what'd you do yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's what you're a
troll yeah
because usually that guy has a matching
hand for his hand and also that was just
everything you had when he wasn't even
expecting it right yeah yeah now you've
got his attention one time somebody did
that to me with a skateboard truck over
the back of that no yeah the whole board
with the truck like that he was like you
got you guys need to get the [ __ ] out of
here didn't crush your [ __ ] skull
right man
yeah but i've got a big head i've got a
thick head like that's probably my
number one attribute when it comes to
fighting so if lewis that's your like
even if lewis gets lucky and lands one i
eat shots i think it's pretty funny
you know maybe not later on that's why i
don't want to do that too much more but
i can give he can have 15 minutes at
full speed
right or 15 minutes yeah it's not going
to go that long but let's say it makes
it all the way
and he punches me in the face for 15
minutes i will totally know like what my
room is and
i'll still be like
hooking up and so tell me about a time
when you've been in a fight street fight
a street fight much of a street fighter
or regular fight fine when when someone
gave you a shot and you're like okay all
right this guy's he's got power more
than i thought maybe you know yeah
excellent one so i'm in england at a
skateboard contest and i'm on the bones
brigade and this dude mike valeli he's
super tough guy
for a skateboarder an angry kind of guy
that is quick to go
usually he's he's probably in the rights
like security guards and stuff like that
he's not a bully of kids it's more of a
protector of of he'll fight bullies
so uh i'm i'm there and what i don't
know is i'd say i did a lot of drugs
back then and i partied a lot so i was
getting on people's nerves in europe
like the team were contemplating sending
me home and i did not know this
so i get to the venue it's a big stadium
and when i get to the venue i come into
the where the ramp is and someone goes
hey alice your [ __ ] boy's in trouble
and i'm like what do you mean and he's
like dude he's over there and i look uh
there's like uh those revolving doors
that they go under the stadium and then
the stairs go out of the stadium and i
see through the doors
people are fighting bunch of people
punching and stuff
so i run in there and it's him and like
12 security guards and he's in the
middle of 12 security guards punching
them just going just going like a
[ __ ] like a cat in a bathtub just
[ __ ]
like just [ __ ] [ __ ] flying everywhere
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is this guy
doing yeah and then i run in i jump in
there because it's 12 of them dude maybe
more it looked like a group of people
and him in the middle of fighting
everybody security oh security okay this
is england man like it's different and
the security are like tatted up guys and
[ __ ] like they're they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
out they're not like they're [ __ ] and
they don't have soccer bullies
yeah all they do is scrap like that
they're good they're good with it so
i get in there and i realize as i i get
in there and uh
he's
his wife and his daughter are
in the middle oh [ __ ] so somebody i
guess somebody said that he didn't have
a pass to get in he was like [ __ ] you
and somebody grabbed him and he pushed
and he was with his wife and child and
his child was probably five something
like that five-year-old daughter
and his wife's little too
so
i uh i get in there and as soon as i
jump in there like some dude [ __ ]
hits me and i [ __ ] i [ __ ] crack
and smash this [ __ ] dude and the dude
just turns around and goes wham and i go
and i'm like
and i was like
and the guy was way bigger than me and i
was like [ __ ] like [ __ ]
the dude was like yeah you need more and
i was like you need something
and he knew he knew that when it hit me
i was like i don't need any more
and he didn't give me any more so i
grabbed i grabbed my friend and his kid
and and and and i [ __ ] start running
up the staircase
with him while he's still fighting them
and i'd go up the stairs a couple more
people punch me in the [ __ ] face with
a kid in your eyes i've got a [ __ ]
kid and a wife gotta love him i got crew
family and i'm somebody punched me
punched
[Applause]
scratch [ __ ]
and then i push out and i grab the kid i
grab the kid
the daughter and and they go out and
he's out the front [ __ ] we gotta get
these [ __ ] and i go yeah yeah
yeah
but first
you go back to the hotel room and take
your wife and daughter back and then you
and i will get these [ __ ] and i i'm
not get i was like hell anybody gonna be
joking that one guy could kill both of
us and he had 12 friends so [ __ ] that
but yeah that was one of those ones
where it was not i had no problem
because i've had fights before where
people are just bigger and
it's not even it's not even scary it's
just like you got me and if you want to
make it worse you go ahead make it worse
but i'm not a [ __ ] you know
what have you been knocked out
uh yeah not in a street fight but i've
been knocked out in the gym
first time what was it like do you
remember
well the first time not because there's
there's there's dazed
and then there's i mean out yeah yeah
when you come to do you know or do you
even believe what people are telling you
or is it yeah yeah yeah it's pretty i
mean if you're out out and you don't
know who you are anymore i've never done
that i've got a pretty thick skull as i
said every time i've been knocked out i
pretty much know who i am one time when
i got knocked out skateboarding real bad
i kept going in and out of consciousness
i didn't know what the i thought i was
dying a couple of times i thought i was
dying people [ __ ] strangling me
thought i was in hell and then i wake up
and i'm in an ambulance and then i go
back away again into this thing people
choking me
freaking me the [ __ ] out man i woke up
in the hospital on the other side
woke up in hospital and as a
fat lady uh wiping my dick and balls
down with the wet towel
and i was like please just she didn't
work i swear to god
but they do look like they got to pee on
them
he's a little clean because i pissed my
pants when i got knocked
out so when i was in this thinking the
people were choking me in this imaginary
uh hell i was in i've i've also pissed
my pants
then my brother came in and i remember
saying i was like it's not cheating
if you mean if you got
if you got knocked out
try to make a joke of a lady touching my
balls i was married to somebody that
wasn't [ __ ] a lot so it was it was a
highlight
so it was like definitely at one point
in hell and like there's things making
me choke and then like somebody's giving
me a free one so what do you so okay so
can we talk about that then uh
not a sexless marriage it sounds like
but not enough
yeah yeah there you go can we talk about
that yeah sure i mean cool for a guy
like you i i don't i guess what i don't
know is you're obviously hypersexual
yeah you're obviously open literally to
[ __ ] anything yeah and anyone well
maybe not anything i don't think you go
animals or anything like that but you
know what i wouldn't put a picture i was
talking about on my show how i would be
into like a beast woman that's what i
feel like yeah but not you not enough
not a monkey woman like a beastly woman
yeah yeah i mean like a wolfy woman like
she's half where like i would [ __ ] a
werewolf lady
what
what
you don't think that's hot
is this weird this is gonna be weird i
wouldn't lick her
but i would have sex with her because i
feel like it's be a i don't like hairy
women i look here's the thing a friend
of mine's wife explained it to me like
this like we just have a stick that we
put in a hole oh yeah the hole yeah so
it doesn't
sound odd to me that you would stick to
so i know what it's like to be a bit of
a lady right
you got to trust them a little more it's
not the same yeah yeah you're letting
them inside you are yeah yeah yeah
you're vulnerable i like that you're
vulnerable right now i feel like i feel
your vulnerability i don't i regret
saying that but it's just you regret it
yeah you're sensitive you have a
sensitive side yeah
it's pretty yep there you go when you're
traveling to a destination where you
don't know the language it can be
challenging to accomplish even the
simplest of tasks i've told you before
you guys heard me talk about i was in
mexico a few months ago
and man that eighth grade mexico
education was not cutting it all right
thankfully there's babel the number one
selling language learning app through
babel's bite-sized lessons you'll learn
new language skills that you can
actually use in the real world from
greetings menus and directions to
gaining a deeper understanding of the
culture babel is a travel essential i
started using babel before they even
came on board here got it for a year um
and i love it i love going through my
lessons once i go through my lessons
they go back through reminders then they
do quizzes they have you speak they have
you actually
fill in blanks type in your phone you're
gonna get a little um
it's like a little world
um keyboard on there it's pretty bad
it's pretty badass i didn't want to cuss
but i'm gonna say it it's badass babel's
15-minute lessons make it the perfect
way to learn a new language on the go
other language learning apps use ai for
their lessons but babel lessons were
created by over 100 language experts
their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german plus babel
speech recognition technology helps you
to improve your pronunciation and your
accent there are so many ways to learn
with babble in addition to lessons you
can access podcasts games videos stories
and even live classes start your new
language learning journey today with
babel right now when you purchase a
three month babel subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use promo code
honeydew that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code honeydew babble language for life
there's a specialist for just about
everything right when your car breaks
down you go to a mechanic when there's a
problem with the shower you call a
plumber so when you want to get your
uneven crooked teeth fixed you see an
orthodontist they're the specialists and
that's what sets candid the invisible
comfortable and removable liners above
the rest while poorly reviewed or
insanely priced clear aligner companies
use general dentist candid only works
with orthodontist with candid the same
orthodontist who created your plan is
with you from start to finish so you
never have to wonder how you're doing
your treatment is prescribed and closely
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement you can book an appointment at
a candid studio near you or do
everything from the comfort and
convenience of your own home the average
candid treatment is just six months
you'll start seeing results way before
then it costs thousands less than the
traditional braces and with your aligner
treatment you'll get candids teeth
whitening for free look
traditional braces man i had everything
and my orthodontist was my dentist he
went from being my dentist to my
orthodontist put the old school braces
on you know the kind that rip your lips
up on inside you have to put wax over
them i had retainers and then rubber
bands after that that are snapping and
popping in my mouth a built-in man come
on you don't need any of that just go
get yourself some candid all right
candid can help you get the straighter
brighter smile you've always wanted
right now you can get started from home
for just 15 bucks with a candid starter
kit or you can book an appointment at a
candid studio near you today go to
candidco.com
honeydew and use code honeydew that's
candidco.com
honeydew code honeydew take advantage of
this limited time offer for a 15 starter
kit candidco.com
honeydew code honeydew autumn is in the
air the pumpkins are in the patch and
our friends at manscape they're here to
make sure you don't carve your pants
pumpkins when you're grooming if you
know what i'm saying make sure you're
keeping things fresh this fall with the
leaders in mail grooming and their brand
new fourth generation performance
package boys get ready for a cuffin
season like no other ready to take the
leap into fall with manscaped join the
two million men worldwide using manscape
by going to manscaped.com
for 20 off plus free shipping with the
code honeydew i've told you before i've
used other trimmers you know trying to
just clean yourself up a little bit down
there be respectful and i'm my taint's
tattered i'm down there bleeding i'm
like why are my underpants bloody first
off the new performance package 4.0
includes the new lawnmower 4.0 if you're
looking to cozy up this fall this
trimmer is essential seal the deal with
manscape's liquid formulations the crop
preserver ball deodorant everyone knows
pumpkin spice lattes and ball deodorant
go hand in hand
manscaped even threw in two free gifts
to their performance package 4.0 you get
the manscape boxers and the shed travel
bag get comfy at home and on the go this
season get twenty percent off plus free
shipping with the code honeydew at
manscape.com that's twenty percent off
plus free shipping with the code
honeydew at manscape.com make your balls
a priority this fall choose manscaped
your balls will thank you now let's get
back to the do where was i going
you got me on a werewolf yeah
i've gotten to know you here over the
last couple years but would you you're
hypersexual obviously but would you say
that's
i don't would you have you always been
that way or is it more of like your
dennis rodman coming into this now and
like i'm leaning into it and having fun
with it
um
or both because i've always been like
super sexual but i didn't know
about any of the things that you could
do
like what what what surprised you
butt play for that was a joke for a
woman or just
yeah well obviously it started with a
woman but i didn't know that anybody did
that or you could do that or or or how
good it was if you did get into what a
woman introduced you
yeah until and like and it wasn't how
does she introduce your fingers or strap
on it took months she just kept working
on it because she kept trying to tell me
she was like months to convince you no
well no i was like i agreed to try and
then it didn't work and then she was
like she was trying to like she's trying
to get a song
one time i took a valium and i drank
because this one person told me to take
a valium and drink a shot a day a
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
because that [ __ ] wasn't happening man
it was i remember at one point i was
like was that fingers if you cut in
there and she's like i haven't even got
my pinky in there you [ __ ] [ __ ] like
let it go already
i couldn't let it go
because it's a mental thing
but then once you let go
you can't look back but all that stuff
and then the way people live you know
like the bdsm stuff all these little
kings let's go no
i didn't know about any of that right so
this girl is sort of a tipping point and
opening you up into a new world of
sexual experience my wife my current
wife yeah she was a person
yeah oh this is this late yeah dude
until i was 40. well i know coming out
but i'm talking about but i'm still a
sexual man in your 20s or 30. but all
the runnings that i had that were
uh
bisexual when i was younger were
accidents that i didn't i i didn't mean
to do i didn't plan out i plan to set
out to do it i just took tons of drugs
and i ended up like some dude blew me
and i was like what the [ __ ] was that
but i put it down to i didn't do a
bomber dude i did seven e-bombers what's
an e-bomber ecstasy pills oh okay like i
didn't [ __ ] play with like people
like yeah we're gonna go out on a
saturday and do an ill
and i'm like how many do you have and
they're like what do you mean i'm like
how many do you [ __ ] have to sell me
because i'm not doing one
you know i do seven and then i you know
i mean
get weird when's the first time you made
love to a man
i'll [ __ ] punch you dude i'll
seriously punch you in the face
[ __ ] you all right i'm being serious
that's the first time
what's the first time that you didn't
take drugs and get black out [ __ ] up
and willfully say all right you say it
like that that's different
let's
i love no man all right i didn't say you
love them i just said you made love it's
cool
the other half is straight as [ __ ]
you'd be surprised
anyway oh yeah
uh yeah i
okay well i had to get sober first so
that was tough and then i think what
year did you get sober how old i've
tried a few times so i've had a few
stints
so i think maybe the first time i had a
stint that was long enough to call
sobriety um was probably 30s you know
okay and i maybe did a i did like a four
years i think
so in the last decade roughly then this
is all pretty good a new thing for you
really
yeah coming out getting clean yeah okay
in the last 10 years yeah it really
really hurt the show too
like a logo i wish i had a [ __ ] joke
for the end of that but
everybody hates my gayness and my
sobriety
everyone's like you know way better
yeah i was like really i love making
jokes about it about that guys screamed
in in traffic girls come and stop me in
traffic i love your card i'm like i know
all right it's [ __ ] stupid
it is
um
first every time i see it on the street
i'm like who's oh wow idiot just hate
jeeps
first time you willfully [ __ ] the dude
right or or okay let me ask it this way
or got [ __ ] by one what was it what
came over the [ __ ] was way later later
oh yeah okay so first time dudes
well man i'm gonna get t-shirts all over
the place get ready guys
listen i have to say this though
[ __ ] dudes when i still had hair the
first time i met you
you the promo for the show is um
uh i sucked the dick when i was three
that's a t-shirt yeah yeah and i mean if
you literally go back and look at that
promo my my i mean it's happened a
couple times my jaw my jaw dropped i
can't even talk about it right now
and it
that's why i love it
it's all
that's awful it's fine you know
jason
i mean my job was like and it took a
second to write you got your accent on
top of
did he just say
and i was like huh oh yeah
all right so oh man
yes a lot a lot of sex when i was real
young and then there was a couple of
breaks
where i got married and had some kids
but i also understand that i feel like
my
uh wife at the time i had kids and and
became
a mother and i really respect her for
that
and and appreciate her for that like did
it work out for me
no you know i mean it was it was it
almost unfair kind of in a roundabout
way if you look at it from my
perspective which is [ __ ] it's a
it's not about you anymore it's about
the kids
she was still loved me but just was like
man
easy jack rabbit you know i mean like
[ __ ] i'll give you some and then that
should be enough and am i
i want to say it is
but i'm lying i i am me and i'm like
yeah one or twice once or twice no you
know i'd rather you were upside down i i
mean i'd rather like i always felt like
i was there was other things that i
wanted to add like i'm one of those
people that started having sex and i
start looking around the room for things
to shove up somebody
it's not enough you know what i mean
like i'm like what about if the camera
was on and i was like shoving something
up my own ass while giving you the
[ __ ] fish hook like it's gotta be
extra stuff it's always gonna be extra
but i mean the more i go to therapy the
less that
is a thing in my life but there's
certain things that i've really got like
i like my weed you know yeah i like it i
mean and i'm not i'm not like that i'm
not ashamed of it embarrassing no hell
and then when it comes to sex i would
rather my kid walk down the sidewalk and
smell marijuana than cigarettes in the
[ __ ] air yeah [ __ ] yeah so let's get
back to the first time you made love to
a
yeah it won't get off it and that's fair
i can't remember i think the first time
i slept with a
because the first time i slept with
somebody
it was a trans woman
so that was probably the first couple of
times but i can tell you the first time
did she still have a penis yes okay yes
and how was that you're into that
yeah yeah yeah
i was still more
sleeping with her because she was a girl
and trying to sleep with her girl parts
more than i was sleeping with her guy
parts this is how you transition yeah
it's like when you get a gold chain
you get a girl chase like the specialty
starter kit yeah it was like it was like
a gay starter kit
you go you go a trans girl but that's
not for everybody i want trans women
getting mad at me
some people just stay in that little
starter kit yeah and they like it there
and that's fine i didn't and i thought
that that was enough for me too but i
didn't i every now and then
to me a little bit more is always better
and and but but not too much too soon
because you freak me out like if someone
was like fist me i'd be like what the
[ __ ] you guys are [ __ ] i'm out of here
but give it 10 years
[Laughter]
and i will punch you in your ass
but the first time i think i slept with
a guy that was real reason that was like
a year ago maybe
really yeah like where i took it
no go back to the the first you still
okay so you went trans first yeah but
when was the first time just a man a
male right a male
who identified as a male how about that
yeah right
um
that was probably
about 15 years ago all right and were
you nervous to do that like did you feel
i was high on meth you were see do you
even remember it yeah yeah yeah i wasn't
yeah i thought it was weird because he
kept calling it a [ __ ]
what your ass his ass he was like [ __ ]
my [ __ ] yeah i was like i hate to break
it to you
i'm not here for this yeah i was like
i know what i'm [ __ ] you know
i wish it was a [ __ ]
if i didn't say that
i was still i was still like had to
start a kid on you know it wasn't it
wasn't totally ready
buttoned up a little bit i didn't want
to talk
around i was like
it's throwing me i mean it's not
it's not it's not a [ __ ]
it's throwing me off
but then it gets kinky you know then i'm
like that's weird as hell and then you
know then like big um
drag queens became super attractive to
me i get really wasted man i go out and
i'm like hi
floating around the bar and some like
10-foot lady's like let me blow you in
the bathroom and i'm like okay
you know they got like crazy magical
wigs and hair and stuff i don't know if
it's a guy i mean it's a guy for sure
but
i don't care it's like magical it's like
a magical [ __ ] and they really want
to do it like more than
anybody that i've ever
let blow me i'm like who am i to judge
this this seems fun you just seem like
it's it's it's always a go big though
it's that go bigger it's not just enough
to go find a guy or a trans and you'd
like to go like you told the last story
about the what was it a 400-pound lady
or something like that that you
you'd go visit i guess i'd like i don't
know i think you say it's like going big
but i don't say to myself that it's is
it bigger than the last time i did
something it's more
it's wild you know sex is wild to me not
all the time like sometimes i like to
have sex like normal
i don't know quick ones in the [ __ ]
chair with my wife like it's not all
just about that but when it gets
when if there is a chance of getting
things wild
how okay how wild do you guys get cause
i've i'm in i'm usually in you know
unless you what's your heart no don't
[ __ ] on me i will knock you the [ __ ] out
but no one's ever tried to [ __ ] i mean i
tell these people try to one time
because i'll go and grind it when i'm
bored you know it's like a app so i'll
go on there and i'll be in different
places and someone's like oh holy [ __ ]
because i look like a straight guy
everyone thinks that's cool like i want
to eat your ass and i'm like yeah man
cool appreciate it you know like it's
almost a compliment people just say that
it's like no seriously that's just the
do people send me on instagram people
send me their [ __ ] hello just dick hi
can i suck you off i'm like you're a
[ __ ] cartoon pitcher your emoji is a
cartoon pitcher can i sit i don't know
you cartoon pitcher like but what about
right now i'm like no right now but then
yeah somebody was like what about if
it's dirty and i was like i'd prefer to
shower you know like ew and it's like no
real dirty and i'm like
okay so honestly
what are we talking here do you really
want to eat [ __ ]
and they're like yeah that's what that
means and then i was like i thought you
got sick from that and then i've had
somebody break it down to me nah uh
every now and then i like to do it and i
would totally do it if you came out i
told my wife and she was like show me
the message because she didn't believe
me and i was like look at the
conversation i had this guy is like come
over and [ __ ] my mouth get the [ __ ] out
right he lives around here
he's local i was he's local
use code honeydew at the santa monica
museum
he's probably been in here
he might be running the trumpet from us
right now he's probably going to come
out of one of your patreon shows shoving
it up is that a shade of
[Laughter]
the streets are crazy
the streets are crazy you ain't lying
there's some weird people out there
there are some freaks out there yeah i
can dig it you know i dig like live your
life as long as you're not hurting
anybody you know i don't disagree i
don't find that
to be i don't hate that person
so what what what surprised you that
you're into
like what was like okay
torture torture like are you into the
cages and [ __ ]
wait where i stay in a cage for a long
time no i'm in a hurry
to come pretty soon the dick cage yeah
you're gonna have no no no no like where
are
you
yeah i'm getting a burner all the time
especially if somebody's i don't touch
them i would want to hold that back i'm
like yeah my one is about having a boner
all the time i don't have like uh yeah
let's have a thing where i stay flaccid
no i don't want to play that game it's
more of they she ties ropes around your
balls and your dick and [ __ ] and yeah
and put weights
on the ropes and it's like horn
porn is the key to it it but then like
slaps and canes on it and stuff but the
pain yeah but she puts a candy cane
like [ __ ] like [ __ ] cracking bad
boy on your ass
and and then like suffocation [ __ ] so
she does all these things you're into
suffocation too yeah i mean man you're
making me sound
i'm not making you sound anyway you're
saying it i'm just asking some people
get panic attacked about being listen
just so you know this this episode will
be demonetized by youtube it's fine we
could talk about hurry up because just
so you know that's why i can't make any
money on youtube anything i say i get
demonetized as soon as my mouth opens i
haven't even told you this recently they
said they had a person go back through
my library and all of yours have been so
i think they know you and joey i can't
do anything yeah this thing doesn't get
any damage i promise you we might get a
handful of downloads then it'll be a
yellow [ __ ] dollar sign
change my [ __ ]
don't why you change who you are for
youtube bro okay good point
all right well then [ __ ] them so okay
you're in the torture like you're into
that huh yeah like not really but yeah
it turns out where i got a mistress and
then she got into that and then it
turned out that yes i did like that
not now are you into the like well i've
seen these japanese videos where they
stomp on these guys now the heels and
[ __ ] these guys are screaming but asking
for more i heard that's kind of fake i
got a friend that's in porn to get a guy
and he said he did some of those and he
said that oftentimes
he hires people and they kick most of
the foot goes in the ass
but it still hurts but he does it for
the money because he makes a lot of
money from the videos but he's not into
it he's the best torture guy some people
are some people like really pay michigan
some people are into everything there's
something out there obviously yes yeah
but i don't want to get uh
what scares you
my ex-wife
what
i ain't [ __ ] with her
i hope she's gonna take that the wrong
way is this the ex-wife you took the 50
grand and uh that you buddy paige and
open your started your business
no that's the wife before
[ __ ] her
not scared of her that's good
[Laughter]
no i like her i think that's why i'm
scared of her she's a nice person
i feel sorry for her a little bit you
know
do you are you in contact with her at
all she's the mother of my children oh
the your first wife is not your second
no my second wife is the mother of my
children my third wife is the one i have
now who's your first wife's name this is
australian chick though
no
remember i told you she was the one okay
yeah
we didn't have kids no kids with her
okay so you have clean ties with her i
mean you're cut yeah good
yeah if and that'd be a different if i
saw her now i would definitely um like
if she walked straight up to me i would
get in a fighting stance not to punch
just to protect myself because i don't
that's how crazy i think that person is
like if she was just walking if she
unless she was like hey i'd be like hey
i wouldn't hug her i'd be like yeah i'm
wrong
i'm good are you cuz i'm trying to just
[ __ ] live is that cool
she scares the [ __ ] out of me it was
that bad huh just don't want to get i
don't it's not it's just like uh
you know
people punching me or hitting me for no
reason is is uh is
mentally scarring to me now you know
like it doesn't it takes that would be a
big hit
if some girl was like the [ __ ] would you
looking at [ __ ] and i wasn't
doing anything and they just punched me
in the face that would trigger me hard
because that that was a thing where i
was just letting it happen and now
i don't let people do things like that
to me anymore so it would be very
complex i'd be like can somebody like
you said they gotta go kick the ball
somebody could somebody get hurt exactly
[Laughter]
that's why i like that my wife now
trains and stuff i'm like if it ever got
down to that
she's got your back hey i'd be like talk
to her about it
she'll piece you up
maybe not but she's she's so sweet i
mean she probably would she looks like
she'd fight though she she really
wouldn't she's very similar to me she
doesn't like actual street fighting
things but she is somebody that likes
pain
you know but not she's like it's the
altercation that she's into i know your
wife she's little too yeah what's what's
uh do you who has the higher pain
tolerance threshold
man probably her
i i don't know it's different like she
has she does tattoos like she got the
back of her legs tattooed from her ass
down to her ankle
and oh my god
yeah oh my gosh
that's [ __ ] so
she just didn't give a [ __ ] about that
so it's like those things but
oh you know what she broke her back she
had like she's in a car crash and she
broke her back and then she's had two
back surgeries but when she got that
first back surgery she looked like she
was in pain
do you look like yeah she was asking for
all the painkillers so she's not that
tough
oh [ __ ]
yeah but she's [ __ ] awesome so what
i'm saying man you get lucky like that
like to be disappointed to find somebody
to let you really
spread your wings and your wings or your
ass well that's what i'm saying my wings
are [ __ ]
big old butt cheeks
it's not everybody wants to let their
husbands spread those you know and to be
quite frank i don't think she
appreciates like i don't she's not like
uh
she's not trying to like you know get on
your knees and let me butt [ __ ] you kind
of girl you know she's she likes me
being a crusher she likes me being the
boss of things but she's like i get it
you want to live different lives you
want to do different stuff in your life
and
don't let me stop you you know if it
makes you happy because i think she can
tell you know there's certain things
that i like to do with certain people
that it's part of my
life that's why what i have left you
know like i don't drink i don't do blow
i don't do [ __ ]
prostitutes i don't i mean i clean up a
lot of things
and i've apologized to a lot of people
for the way that i've acted in my life
and now the things that i do they don't
hurt anybody if anything they make the
other people that i do it with makes
their day too
and we're we're all good with it you
know everybody can tell you this can
come out my kids can see it
dad did it
dad did it if your friends want to make
fun of you for what your dad did
go ahead but just know that people live
their lives people get [ __ ] in the ass
there's nothing wrong with it
got [ __ ] in the house the other day
i'm [ __ ] very happy about it she
gonna do about it stop me on the street
try to [ __ ] what are you gonna no
one's gonna stop me from doing anything
i'm very happy with it
told my wife about it
oh
jesus all right
let's uh i have questions for you so
let's talk about uh you said recently
was the first time you got [ __ ] by a
guy yeah yeah because that's my new
thing that's what do you mean your new
thing well now i can do that now that
you're like submissive
yeah
powerbomb no i'm a no
no it's called a flip you're a flip
[ __ ] what's that mean it means you're
top and a bottom you can flip a lot of
people can't do it a lot of people this
is crazy people claim
all bottoms claim their verse and all
bottoms it's a trap
wait
what do you mean if you're a bottom you
you claim your verse first means that
you can top and bottom okay so but you
but people peop most guys just want to
get bottomed once they figure out how to
get bottomed guys don't start playing
anything else anymore because it's a
better orgasm well i'm sure yeah i'm
sure
but some guys to me
you're just saying i'm wrong but morgay
is someone who's a total bottom to me
that's a little more gay like a guy even
though it's totally gay to go around
banging dudes yeah yeah it's just more
of a you're the manly it's just it's so
stupid you know john waters line and the
movie pecker the guy goes they go you're
gay goes i ain't gay i don't blow them
they blow me that's exactly what he said
that's his logic right which which i get
yeah sure it's gay turned down just a
little bit but you're still on the
[ __ ] i can still hear your game buddy
you're coming in loud and clear over
here
so it's not completely true but it is a
little bit there is a little fact to it
but um yeah once i kind of figured out
how to do stuff with my wife
with a with a strap-on or a dildo or
whatever
then obviously it's kind of like
those toys are pretty good but they're
not as good as the real thing like they
just don't make things that fit in you
as comfortable as
this is so gross i feel weird talking to
you about it well let me just say this
like a rubber thing is a little stickier
and stuff you need different stuff to
make it work and real dicks work better
great all right wait for the [ __ ]
primer so it sounds like uh no condom
then
yeah yeah yeah i'm on prep
what's that it's a thing that stops you
from contracting hiv really yeah what
about any other did you know that if you
have a or the if you're still okay you
still get everything else well i don't i
don't i'm i'm not a [ __ ] giant hoe
bagger right i just don't deliver the
ass for all [ __ ]
all right i got two regular dicks that
go in there all right and i check with
one of them
i got a couple of rubber friends as well
but who's the who's the guy that you
were like okay i'm gonna let this guy
take my ass virginity
oh well that didn't count dude yeah it
did i already got my ass rejected i'm
talking about
yes
yeah when i agree yeah when you were
like yep i'm gonna do this
um
it was the only person you don't say
obviously
did i know the person yeah yeah when
some dude random dude it was with a
rubber too
because this is when i was still i
hadn't taken prep and i was still like
uh i didn't do guys i was more of you
could just suck me off that was it
because i was like i don't want to get
anything from it yeah i'm saying this
all scares me and then when talking to
my wife about it i was like she's like
if you're going to do stuff like you may
as well just be smart about it and just
get on all the things and then you won't
have to worry about that like you don't
want to worry about getting hiv and i'm
like i agree and she's like if you're
going to do butt stuff and you you wanna
you think you're gonna do it again in
your life why not just take that [ __ ]
pill you don't drink like it won't do
anything to you there's no side effects
and i was like yeah okay so i do
so if it ever does come up and now it
does because i have two people but both
those two people have other partners oh
so it could still
even though i
kind of trust them i kind of don't you
know so i i i only i just take that pill
and it's only those two and if there's a
new person then it's kind of more of a
you know a dating thing where you get to
know them before you let that happen
because you're like you know do you for
sure really not do any hard drugs
because i know i know a lot of people
still are okay with it but i'm not yeah
i just feel like if you're around my age
and you're still like every now and then
you do a key bump of meth i i i don't
need your dick anywhere near me i'm all
right
just don't need to risk it
it's your dick i love it
it's good here's here's what i want to
talk about you've been married twice
three times yeah what have you learned
in this marriage that you wish you maybe
not wish because you seem to be happy
but that you i still wish it because i
believe those people were treated uh
incorrectly i could have been a better
husband even if we were not together
they didn't deserve to go through any of
that [ __ ] i didn't deserve to go through
what they put me through either i'm not
saying it was just all one-sided but i
definitely don't listen i only think
about myself i spent years like
skateboard skateboard skateboard
skateboard like what then i get into
radio radio radio radio i didn't [ __ ]
it's all about me what's gonna be next
is the me show followed by a little bit
more than me [ __ ] but listen that
also i say this a lot like i feel sorry
for people to live with it i agree but
what we do is selfish it's a one it's
like i say all the times comedy's a solo
sport it's like tennis we don't have a
team of 10 other guys with us and it is
selfish we've left family friends our
homes our everything and we still go for
this one things just by the
i don't mean that we're bad people in
any way but by the nature of what we do
and what we've lived and set ourselves
up you're always talking you're always
thinking about it i mean even when
you're not doing it we're talking again
it's always us it's selfish everybody i
talk to is only talking about that so
they're never totally included
and then i feel like i did that a little
bit with my kids like i think i got
lucky with having them a little bit
later in life and gathering what was
important but still i missed time you
know there was still a few
in the heyday of that serious xm [ __ ] i
was way more into
doing the show than spending time with
the kids you know i can admit it now but
like now i'm trying to hang out with
them and they're busy trying to do stuff
i'm like that's what you get dude you
had your [ __ ] window but you were
like i'm gonna be the next howard stern
so let's do this do that yeah i'll take
that interview i'll do any interview
i'll fly to new york tomorrow like i
would go anywhere at any second for any
interview because
i thought it was my next big thing and
you know can you can the kids come like
no i didn't [ __ ] ask sometimes just
yeah just let me go
it's all you're thinking about so now i
might
i really would like those back you know
because in the end
being big on the radio doesn't really
mean [ __ ] no nobody even [ __ ] cares
none of it does and i don't even care
now i mean i would easily give up
everything just to be a dad if that was
my only choice yeah so i hate that
that's probably the biggest pain in my
life is divorced and wow less
you know i don't have as much money now
so i don't have the power that i used to
have so i don't get the kids as much
so
i still i mean and they're busy they're
like teens and so only
16 and 12 16 and 12. and they want to do
their things you know so it's like you
get
you get you get a you get a good one in
every now and then but every now and
then it's not enough you know i'm like
[ __ ] like every now and then we bro down
and then
who knows the next time we like bro down
if you're there in my house every day
every night
it's more chances of that happening and
now i don't have that i feel like you're
getting further away from me how close
do they live
about an hour okay yeah
so
but you know my daughter is super busy
now she's just you know she's got school
and then she's got her friends and
i'm not cool right you don't want to and
i don't want to bugger i don't want to
like hey spend some time with your dad
and just be lame for a few hours like
don't be lame for a few hours like go
with your friends live your [ __ ] life
so yeah there's that thing where i'm
like oh man you know what you did for a
second there
you rock and rolled out didn't you you
thought it was way more important it
could have even i could have even argued
with her
and and proven myself correct in this
was more important than me being at home
you know because i'm going to make it
i'm going to be a star people are going
to recognize me
the [ __ ] dude
i mean that's powerful and honest for
you to admit you know i i say all the
time i genuinely don't give a [ __ ] about
fame i it may come up
that's why i can admit it's [ __ ] it's
just
it's embarrassing i just want to be the
same [ __ ] in a different tax bracket
that is yeah i heard you say that i
believe you i put that [ __ ] up on
[ __ ] i believe you that's why
you know we we talk about this and it's
like
i mean i guess i know i i
you know it's what i my trauma i live
with like man my dad i would love
the time my dad was like you want to run
up to the store with me real quick and
get some [ __ ] to go crabbing tomorrow
like nah i'm just going to play video
games you go grab it right oh
that happened what do i do to [ __ ]
have that hour hour and a half with him
right but that's like what crazy what i
would have done with that conversation
too it's sure not gonna be
some [ __ ] about school and whatever
you know but
i i try to have those moments with my
daughter like i just hug her all the
time and she's like dad you know you she
can't [ __ ] take it and i'm like you
don't
you know or if i say you know what are
you gonna do when i'm not around she's
like shut up yeah i'm like i'm [ __ ]
you don't know you know might not be
around like can we just hang out a
little bit it's getting to that point
like i'm very proud that i've introduced
my daughter to who my father was i show
her pictures of them all the time she
knows grandpa lefty she cried one night
she in bed were laying she started
crying why are you crying she's like
because i miss grandpa lefty and i um
dude
it [ __ ] blew me away i started crying
i'm like
this little [ __ ] child that wasn't
even didn't even exist when my pain
first happened is feeling her own man it
tripped me out and we laid there and i
was like you know what
so i teach her about her
great-grandmother you know my grandma my
dad and it's starting to get to the
point now where she's like well you had
you know grandma judy there i was like
ah actually grandma was gone well why i
can't understand you know i try to i'm
i'm learning how to tell
her that like i just say yeah she wasn't
well for a while and you know whatever
like 25 30 years
i'm in the same boat i can't you know i
don't see exactly what happened in my
childhood you know my kids know that
something bad happened in my childhood
and
like there's little hints there where i
think my daughter kind of knows you know
but i've never just flat out said it for
me
i feel like they're too young to know
about it yeah they are and i'm and i'm
so like
grateful for everything that this
podcast does for me for my family and
and for my guests and their stories and
for the fans that constantly are sending
me
you know hey this is saving my life
but i'm so [ __ ] glad that i've been
able to keep my father and my
grandmother alive through these stories
and that more than anything when i'm
gone my daughter can sit and listen to
any of this [ __ ] and hear exactly what
we did who we were
you know it doesn't matter people like
your dad's a dick or your dad was great
your dad whatever it's you listen to
this and just make that decision for
yourself it's all here it's unfiltered
it's as real as it [ __ ] gets it's
brutal it's ugly it's beautiful so i'm
glad that we are able to do this type of
show and and have that for our kids to
listen to yeah and just because there's
bad stuff in it doesn't make it bad
anyway like i feel like there's tons of
bad stuff about a lot of people in my
family but there's a lot of good stuff
about it yeah
and that i have both of those in in me
and i have i have the the choice to
to you know decide which path to go down
you know like because i feel that you
know there's a voice in there it's like
just do all the [ __ ] bumps again you
know i mean [ __ ]
fight everybody set the world on fire
and i'm like it's funny it's funny that
that courses through my veins what a
childish thing that i have like out my
relatives
they must have really i'm surprised that
they lived long enough to come in an
adult to make a baby because boy did i
we only have bad decisions you know i
don't know how we our family gene made
it to like adulthood
like how did we actually decide to get
like go the right way and become a man
because we're crazy
but then the other part of me well i
thought about this today too like
testosterone just testosterone yeah
i'm curious
if there are gonna be trans
men
who are gonna be like
i'm sorry
you know what i mean like i had no idea
we're
full of testosterone right now i had a
guy on my show the other day that was
born a girl now he's a guy i boxed him
he's a pro boxer
he used to be a female boxer now he's a
mailboxer and he's a dude and he can
kick ass and i was like how's that
testosterone when you first got on it
he's like it's amazing
right so we're cheating yeah what what
women don't realize is that like
testosterone while you're over there
possibly journaling and you know talking
to your girlfriends like we'll go [ __ ]
somebody in a cave like it it's not it's
not here all the time it is the [ __ ]
that will drive you like
i probably shouldn't i remember getting
in strange girls cars like when i was in
you know my 20s and 30s out here in la
we'd meet him at a bar and then me and
my buddy get i'll never forget he looked
at me he's like we're in a stranger's
car we're in a stranger's car running a
stranger's guard i was like why are you
bro what did you do
out of a club in florida with i i
supposed to do a demo and it got rained
out so i just started drinking the whole
day and i guess ken block's wife because
they lived in florida she was escorting
me out of the club because i was so
[ __ ] wasted and i guess she looked
one way as a car drove by with a bunch
of fat chicks in it and i just [ __ ]
dove head first into the back window no
and and lucy was like no
and she said that my legs just drove off
in a vehicle out of florida out into the
night
and i just disappeared but they went to
a hotel room where unwritten law was and
then i drank all these this band
i was gonna say is that an actual thing
but i knew the singer he like hired me
once to do skateboarding in one of their
music videos and i was like hey it's the
rock and roll guide he's like hey a
skateboard guy and i was like let me
drink all your alcohol and try to have
sex with those large ladies and then i
drank so much that i did the you know
when you hold on to the toilet and vomit
and then they wrote dick on my head yeah
and then they drew a dick on my head
to the guy that dove in their vehicle
yeah and i didn't sleep with anybody
which is that's the other time where i
try to sleep with a really large lady at
a contest
we were at a nightclub afterwards and
you see really large 400 420
biggest girl i've ever tried to sleep
with
and i was a young man and i was at the
club and she was looking at me so i was
like [ __ ] i'll go talk to her and
this is back when skateboarding i was
still pretty cool and some of my
skateboard friends were like really dude
and this was i was like yeah
yeah really
like
[ __ ] you man like yeah i'm gonna try and
[ __ ] this the biggest lady
ever
i remember her i was trying to hold on
to her and her head was as far away as
you were and her titties were on me no
she was gigantic dude and i got this
hotel room because i did well in this
contest
so i got a room with a jacuzzi because i
always had player like i was ready to
pimp when i didn't have any money it's
kind of like a bit of a shitty conor
mcgregor before conor mcgregor where i
was like if i got any money i just
bought like something fabulous with it
so i got this room that i couldn't
afford and it had a [ __ ] the outdoor
jacuzzi in the room it's confusing
but i remember i'm so wasted and i get
back to the house and i remember making
out with her several times on the way to
the hotel room and also mentioning how
hard i was going to give it to her when
i got to the room so big brag about how
i'm going to give it to you don't even
worry about it and then i get to the
room and i get in jacuzzi and she gets
in the jacuzzi and i remember watching
it like it was slow-mo like when she
took all her clothes off because i never
seen anybody that large naked before and
i was like whoa
because her back had
like different wrinkles that people
don't have and i'm like wow that is
crazy not gross i'm like whoa i didn't
even know people could do that and then
she had to do the she did the had to do
the leg
scissor over to get in like andre the
giant over the top rope
the beef area
had not seen
anything for a long time so it was like
this [ __ ] unfolding like you know the
predator's mouth like this layer
and it's compressed because it's just
been [ __ ] getting it right goodness
and it was like
and then back here
jacuzzi and we fool around i'm like
alright let's get in the bed and then i
get it i lie i get on the bed and i fall
on my back
on the bed and she starts blowing me
and i pass out
so i wake up in the morning she's not
there
i check my wallet in the fridge and i'm
like
didn't take anything the fridge
i didn't mean that you know what i mean
i had
dude i was poor man it was like kit kats
in there and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it was a really nice hotel it had like
the best snacks dude
like all the kids
for sure the fridge is gone for sure and
i'm like whoa
not even one candy bar
solid
solid chick it felt really bad
oh my god so i didn't i didn't do it
oh all right but it was the thought that
counts you know well i gotta say look i
i can't
thank you for coming in here
yeah we're gonna i mean what else we're
gonna wrap it up there bro we're gonna
wrap it up there promote let me say this
again too real quick i didn't say it at
the top thank you for coming in thanks
for having me it's late as [ __ ] at night
uh i want to thank any i want to thank
nadav josh potter kirsten everybody
uh stefan martine everybody that has
stepped in here to help in some way uh
we've had some a wild couple of weeks is
all i'll say
um you know we're getting everything
straightened out so i appreciate you
coming in to me you know
talk about your [ __ ]
your low lights bro goddamn
um plug again the the fight and
everything oh alex manny you can't get
tickets yet maybe you could get tickets
by when this comes out but just type in
alice mania or uh if you go to my
website vjsanellis.com
i believe if you just type in jason
ellis on google it will show you
me and my potential event
and and look if it doesn't happen i'm
probably going to go to skank fest i'm
definitely going to skank fest anyway so
that's november 7th so i'll be there to
promote and maybe i'll just knock out
louis at skank fest
all right so in the next after it's
either louis is snoring november 7th or
any day
from there on
all right i i also don't want to forget
to thank tom and christina as well all
right uh i am ryan sickler as always
ryan sickler.com ryan zickler on all
social media we will talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you